[Music]
hello and welcome to this video which is
part seven of our course about how to
fight a forum like Caruana video 7
chapter 7 him is the first chapter that
deals with White's most popular move
against the petrov that is to capture on
e5 probably also the most natural
movement the pawn is hanging so why not
take it yeah this is the main move in
terms of game count and also
traditionally always was reviewed as
seen as the probably critical tribe we
are dealing with this move in three
chapters and I would like to briefly
show you the structure of those chapters
so what's in this video was it in the
others after Knight takes e5 black ghost
e6 and we have now two overwhelming main
lines and a couple of side lines the
main lines are Knight f3 94 and now
white well traditional main line what I
call the old main line is d4 and then we
go d5 Bishop d3 Bishop d6 this is
chapter eight and one of the principal
tries that white has against the petrov
and the so called modern main line is
Knight to c3 this is dealt with in
chapter 9 the final chapter of our
course so those two yeah main parts of
90 85 are dealt with in separate videos
this video is looking at all the
possible side lines that white may play
to get to avoid those
yeah well trodden path so what is
possible there instead
after d6 when the knight is hanging
and has to make some kind of commitment
and the first move that we're going to
look at is a controversial one and that
is night xf7 the so called cochran
gambit white gives up a piece very early
on and we of course have to take it now
let's have a look yeah why does
sacrificing a piece already on move form
and he gets only two pawns for it
what white ones do with the sacrifice is
to build up a huge Center he does not
want to and that would fail really
miserably trying to do that he doesn't
want to checkmate black right out of the
opening but rather wants to build up
something that looks like with 93d form
f4 maybe later
e5 a little bit like a pawn steamroller
in the center where the black king is
also feeling slightly insecure
this is why it's idea and if black does
not play as yeah we nowadays know it's
best what is best then black will
actually be in some trouble so it's
absolutely advisable to study my
recommendation here play like that if
you do that I think it would be Wyatt
was rather in trouble but we have to
admit that this Knight takes f7 while
not being good it's not losing straight
away that is not a line that should cost
white the game it just it's definitely
rather in trouble of anything else if
black plays correctly so let's have a
look how it continues we can start with
the move that is absolutely not
dangerous and that is Bishop c4 check
against this we go d5 attacking both the
pawn and the bishop and here the problem
is that white actually has to take now
this idea of rolling the pawns forward
is gone now with this structure there's
simply no f4 d45 happening and after
Bishop d6 we are ready to
yeah castle by Hendrik f8 King g8 and
black has an excellent position we can
use our extra piece to attack that it's
very important I'm giving up a piece
like that as why did gives us an extra
piece to attack here black is in
excellent shape going back to the
starting position of the Cochran White's
most dangerous principle tries on 90 c3
and deform against Knight c3 I recommend
to play the move c5 and follow the
footsteps of some some strong players
that had this on the board already in
particular Kramnik played this in a game
against hope our loved ones T'Pol off
really went a bit wired damn who hit
going for the Cochran still quite
surprised that he would would place a
Jim yeah questionable line so why c5
it's not the most obvious move but you
understand it better if you see that
after deform we will also play c5 the
ideas to attack white centre and
immediately prevent that he gets this d4
in forever
f4 on the board if we play against
Knight c3 c5 we were very often just
transpose into positions that could
start from D 4 C 5 and here white
normally plays Bishop c4 check looks
very logical go Bishop e6 we take only
six okay I'm sorry for left it's good a
bit of an issue here with the with the
server King take c6 and here white
normally goes for D form which looks
like a very obvious move you want to
develop the c1 Bishop after D form we do
transpose into the mentioned line 5d 45
by going King to f7 we want to secure
the King D takes e5 and knight c6
yeah completely not caring about keeping
a pond but developing quickly here
blacks development is a lot better we
have the night out both nights out and
after a later capture on d6 we will have
this developed as well so black has
excellent development we will look at
this exactly this position in a moment
when we switch to the lion 5d form in
this situation besides deform white has
tried to move g4 which is a bit of a
crazy
I'm sorry crazy looking decision but and
white is a piece down and he has to do
something to justify his material
deficit g4 was actually played in a
grandmaster game surprisingly between
Mackenzie mana and been fine gold and
fine gold played aged six to stop the
pawn d3 a 96 and now f4 yeah why
definitely yeah I would form out for
blood with the setup but if you check
this like here King de 7 it's that good
for white I don't believe it no black
has many pieces around the King and
after all a piece is a piece wise head
what is a little bit of an initiative
because we have to react for a moment
but I don't think the king is really in
danger we can always hide on the Queen
side so in most cases this Knight c3
move after c5 and the sequence continues
with D form and then we will get after
king f7 d c5
exactly a position that we will now look
at in detail most of the time
why to disco still for deform and after
deform we should play the move c5 as I
mentioned this is the best move and very
much the only move I think that does
endanger or question White's play you
should definitely not play something
like Bishop e7 or g6 or Bishop e6 moves
that trying to
just developed slowly and let's see what
Y does in this case white will get this
F form and so on in and it will be yeah
in a practical game it is very difficult
to play also note that of course we
cannot take this as Queen age five it's
very annoying we have to step onto the
e-file now and then we lose the knight
back surprising that a couple of strong
players fell into this little trap
so c5 is what we have to do and I think
young black can be quite happy about the
resulting positions if white now checks
we have seen the same idea before that
white might check if you enjoyed the
free video preview make sure to go to
chesterlaw.com slash fight like a karana
to get to the full course the full
course with the move trainer and video
sync technology is an excellent way to
learn all the ideas and strategies
connected to this repertoire these lines
were essential in Kiwanis fight to get
the world title match and they can be an
essential part of your opening
repertoire as well
[Music]